لا تزال الإكوادور غارقة في أزمة أمنية عميقة
قبل أسابيع قليلة من
الانتخابات العامة، وفقًا
لدائرة السجون في البلاد، حيث يتم احتجاز أكثر من 90 من
حراس السجون حاليًا كرهائن
داخل العديد من السجون من قبل
السجناء الذين يطالبون
بظروف أفضل، ويأتي ذلك في عطلة
نهاية أسبوع أخرى من العنف.  داخل
سجون الإكوادور حيث أسفرت الاشتباكات عن
مقتل ما لا يقل عن ستة سجناء خلال
الأيام القليلة الماضية، ويوم الأحد قُتل عمدة مدينة
مانتا، سادس أكبر مدينة في الإكوادور،
في هجوم
وصفته الحكومة بأنه عمل إرهابي أعلنه
الرئيس المنتهية ولايته غييرمو لاسو.  حالة
الطوارئ في
مقاطعتين في البلاد وتعهد
بتقديم الجناة إلى العدالة،
كما طلب عقد اجتماع
لمجلس الدولة والأمن العام يوم الثلاثاء،
ومن المقرر إجراء الانتخابات العامة
في 20 أغسطس والمرشحين الثلاثة الرئيسيين
الذين  يتنافسون ليكونوا
البديل الأخير، وقد أعربوا جميعًا عن
تعازيهم بشأن الجرائم
وتعهدوا جميعًا باستعادة الثقة
في الأجهزة الأمنية في البلاد
ووضع دوامة العنف هذه تحت
السيطرة لشبكة CNN، هذا هو ستيفانو بوغوتا